it used to be that when you were an
author you hoped your book would hit the
new york times bestseller list if it did
your book sales would skyrocket
traditional outlets like the new york
times once wielded power and prestige
they could influence everything from the
books you buy to the people you vote for
some say but the power of mainstream
media is waning
although cnn saw a considerable spike in
viewership during the capital riots as
it tends to do when there's breaking
news their audience numbers on most days
are abysmal
when cnn touted in this press release
howard beat out msnbc in views in april
2022 it ironically revealed that its own
numbers weren't that great cnn's
flagship shows often bring in less than
200 000 daily views in the key 25 to 54
demographic
yet even their views online are often
less than those of independent youtubers
why are powerful networks with millions
of dollars of backing behind them
getting fewer views than some individual
content creators
i thought about my time working as a
television reporter most recently in
london a new day in a new prime minister
good morning anne-marie i've compared
that with my work now as an online
content creator there's a massive
difference between videos that are made
by tv networks and videos that are made
by youtubers even though both are video
oriented online content creators have a
lot more creative freedom which often
makes for more compelling content i can
make a six minute video about the
difficulty of landing starship or a 23
minute video about the dark web crime
kingpin of silk road
you don't get the luxury of that much
time with television take the example of
interviews you might notice that the
format of web-only interviews is
different from interviews made for tv
that are then released online when joe
rogan speaks to guests for his podcast
the conversation seems natural and
unscripted and often lasts anywhere from
two to four hours
whereas tv interviews are time sensitive
because they have to move on to another
segment it has to be solidarity i have
to end it there because we're out of
time we'll be back
as a result interviews often sound like
sound bites or may appear inauthentic
even when tv feels authentic you're
still restricted by time
in this hilarious segment from global
news the canadian network where i used
to work one of the hosts made an
artichoke dip and it went horribly wrong
but there's no vinegar in there so
here's what happens what
that's like all that i can do
oh my god
okay so
like it's caught i'm not trying to be
rude here it's okay i agree with you
this was fantastically entertaining and
could have gone on for longer but they
had to cut to a commercial break or
another segment i felt these time
constraints myself my stories were only
one minute and 30 seconds long because
so many stories have to be squeezed into
the nightly newscast usually an hour
long
time constraints hurt storytelling
because you can't delve deeply into a
topic
shows such as 60 minutes offer longer
form reporting but they don't air daily
because they take considerable resources
to produce when daily tv reports are
later uploaded online their short rigid
format fails to compel people to watch
for example my report about a zero-waste
grocery store in the uk may have gotten
hundreds of thousands of views when it
aired on television stations in north
america yet it only received 600 views
on youtube when uploaded by a local
chicago station or take bloomberg
technology's youtube channel they simply
re-upload segments from their tv program
online the result is just a few thousand
views per video
it's hard for networks to produce
content that works well for online
because their storytelling is beholden
to the format for television and the
advertising dollars it brings you'd be
hard-pressed to find a network willing
to do an in-depth review of the iphone
sc like on mkbht's tech channel or a
12-minute video about why black balls
are floating on a reservoir like on
veritasium science channel because tv
audiences don't have long attention
spans for that kind of storytelling
so why is it that when cnn focused on
online video by launching a streaming
service it flopped
cnn plus was touted as the netflix of
news cnn's hired hundreds of people and
created dozens of new shows for the
service it featured original series
documentaries news shows and live daily
programming instead of the 2 million
subscribers that the head honchos at cnn
anticipated after a year
cnn plus reportedly drew fewer than 10
000 views a day
the service shut down in april after
just one month
pretty much no one wanted to pay 5.99 a
month to watch news shows where they can
watch videos on youtube for free
even netflix is struggling to retain
subscribers partly because of price
hikes and again cnn plus shows still
maintained the familiar format of a tv
broadcast which doesn't work well for
the web
although the brains behind cnn plus felt
it stood out because of its interactive
feature where viewers could ask
questions
it really wasn't anything unique
reddit has been doing that for nearly
two decades
cnn banked on its brand name to carry
the day but it was a humiliating failure
traditional outlets used to be the
gatekeepers of information if you wanted
to know what was going on in the world
you got your news from the radio your
local newspaper or on tv
now anybody can be a reporter
some argue this opens the door to
disinformation as professional
journalists are the ones trained to fact
check however there are also accusations
that media outlets can't be trusted
either this media bias chart created by
the company ad fontes media shows the
perceived political leaning of various
news outlets
instead of despairing about their demise
media organizations have to reinvent
their format or face certain death when
everyone cuts the cord which is
inevitable
social media platforms have made it
possible to accumulate millions of views
even without the backing of a
multi-million dollar organization
if you want to learn how to make videos
like mine you don't have to go to a
fancy school or take an expensive course
you can learn on skillshare
skillshare is an online learning
community with thousands of inspiring
classes there's a great class with ali
abdel and how to edit videos it's great
for both beginners and those who want to
brush up on what they already know
polymatter has amazing classes on how to
make great thumbnails which are super
important you got to get them to click
before they watch and mkbhd walks you
through the whole process from start to
finish of scripting shooting and editing
there's something for everyone and you
can try skillshare out for free by going
to my custom link in the description and
pin comment
thanks for watching for newsthink i'm
cindy palm